This video is about rapid progress in
AI. Progress that might soon be a little
less US- ccentric with news of a veteran
OpenAI researcher being denied a green
card. But it's been just a singledigit
number of days since the release of 03,
the latest model from OpenAI. And it has
broken some records and in turn raised
yet more questions. So, in no particular
order and drawing on a halfozen papers,
here are four updates on the state of
play at the bleeding edge of AI. Now,
just before we get to how much money
these models will make for companies
like OpenAI and Google and how much
money they will cost you, which model is
actually the best at the moment? Well,
that's actually really hard to say
because it depends heavily on your use
case and the benchmark that you look at.
At the moment, the two clear contenders
for me would be 03 and Gemini 2.5 Pro.
And I covered how they were neck andneck
in some of the most famous benchmarks in
the video I released on the night of
03's release. But since then, we've
arguably got some more interesting
benchmark results. Take the piecing
together of puzzles within long works of
fiction up to say around 100,000 words.
I honestly expected Gemini 2.5 Pro to
keep its lead in that it could piece
together those puzzles even at various
lengths through to the longest texts.
After all, long context is Gemini's
specialtity. But no, 03 takes the lead
at almost every length of text. If you
know that there's a clue in chapter 3
that pertains to chapter 16, then 03 is
the model for you. Who cares about that?
Some of you will say, "What about
physics and spatial reasoning?" Well,
here is a brand new benchmark from less
than 72 hours ago, and we can compare
those top two contenders. We have Gemini
2.5 Pro in the lead, followed by 03
High. And bear in mind that Gemini 2.5
Pro is four times cheaper than 03.
Notice though, for reference that human
expert accuracy on this benchmark still
far exceeds the best model. Imagine you
had to learn about all sorts of
realistic physical interactions
predominantly through reading text, not
experiencing the world. You would
probably have the same problems. And
honestly, this explains much of the
discrepancy between the top two models
and the human baseline on my own
benchmark, Simple Bench. Those two
models are starting to see through all
the tricks on my benchmark, but they're
still failing quite badly on spatial
reasoning. This isn't a question from
Simple Bench or the physics benchmark,
but it illustrates the point that if,
for example, you put your right palm on
your left shoulder and then loop your
left arm through the gap between your
right arm and your chest, well, you're
probably following, but models have no
idea what's going on. It's not in their
training data, and they can't really
visualize what's happening. I will come
back to this example later, though,
because soon with tools, I could see
them getting this question right.
Speaking of getting questions right, we
learned that 03 beats out Gemini 2.5 Pro
on a test of troubleshooting complex
vyology lab protocols. 03, you will be
glad to know, gets a 94th percentile
score. This is, of course, a textbased
exam and isn't the same as actually
conducting those protocols in the lab.
You might notice I'm balancing things
out because now for a benchmark in which
Gemini 2.5 Pro exceeds the performance
of 03 competition mathematics. Now, you
may have heard on the grapevine the 03
and 04 mini actually got
state-of-the-art scores on AIM 2025.
That is a high school maths competition.
Without tools, both models got around
90%, but with tools, they got over 99%.
What you may not know is that AIM is
just one of the tests used to qualify
for USMO. That is a significantly harder
proof-based maths test. Notice all of
these are high school tests though,
which is very different from
professional mathematics. Anyway, on the
USMO, you can see here that we have 03
on high settings getting around 22%
right compared to 24% for Gemini 2.5.
Again, four times cheaper for Gemini.
What's perhaps more interesting is that
the USMO is only a qualifier for the
hardest high school math competition.
That's the International Math Olympiad.
and Google has a system, Alpha Proof,
that got a silver medal in that
competition. Now, I've done other videos
on Alpha Proof, but I would predict that
in this year's competition in July, I
suspect Google might get gold. Back to
some more downto-earth domains, though.
What about simple visual challenges like
this one? Given an image, can the model
answer, "Is the squirrel climbing up the
fence or is the squirrel climbing down
the fence with these two images?" Are
these two dogs significantly different
in size? As another question, this
benchmark is called natural bench. And
you probably guessed, cuz I'm
alternating in performance, 03 actually
scores better than Gemini 2.5. Both of
course still well behind human
performance. Despite that first
impression, it's actually Gemini 2.5 Pro
that scores better at geoging, being
given a random street view and knowing
which country and location within that
country you're looking at. In fact, the
difference is quite stark with 2.5 Pro
way exceeding 03 high. Now I think of
it, probably not too surprising given
Google's ownership of Google Maps,
Google Earth, and of course YouTube and
Whimo. Last benchmark, I promise. But
how about Visual Puzzles? Which kite has
the longest string here? The answer is
C. And overall on the visual puzzles
benchmark, we have Gemini 2.5 Pro even
underperforming 01, let alone 03. Both
of course still well behind the average
human let alone an expert human. Now
allow me if you will 30 more seconds
before we get to the question of money
because OpenAI basically gave away the
VAR method they use to improve so much
in vision. You may have noticed how 03
seems to zoom in to answer a question.
But what's the executive summary of VAR?
Essentially the model gets overwhelmed
by a highresolution image. So what the
method does is it uses a multimodal LM
to guess at what part of the image is
going to be most relevant to the
question. That part of the image is then
cropped added to the visual working
memory the context of the model along
with the original image and submitted
with the question. You can see that in
action when I gave 03 this where's Wally
or Americans say where's Waldo image.
The language model speculates that Waldo
tends to show up in places like a top
vantage point or a walkway. So, it
decides to crop that area. Now, I will
say in keeping with the other benchmarks
we saw, it wasn't actually able to find
Waldo, and I was, although it took me
about 3 minutes, I'll be honest. Okay,
those are the state-of-the-art models in
AI. But where is this all heading? Well,
to $174 billion of revenue for OpenAI in
2030, according to themselves. In a
moment, I'll touch on what that means
for you in terms of price, but actually
on that prediction seems pretty
reasonable to me. Even though in 2024
they made just $4 billion, I could see
that growing extremely rapidly. I would
note though that even with the biggest
figures being far less than 1% of the
value of white collar labor globally,
someone would have to be spectacularly
wrong. Either as I suspect, we won't get
a country of geniuses in a data center
in 2026 2027 or these figures are
spectacular underestimates. Here then
are some of my very summarized thoughts
about why I think AI is becoming maybe
has already become pay to win or another
way of putting that why me or you might
have to pay more and more and more to
stay at the cutting edge of AI. We got
news just the other day that Google is
planning their own premium plus and
premium pro tiers probably on the order
of $100 $200 a month just like open AI
and very recently anthropic as well. Now
think about it. If AGI or super
intelligence was quote one simple trick
away, one algorithmic tweak or a quick
little scale up of RL, well then these
companies incentives would be to get
that AGI out as soon as possible to
everyone safety permitting. Capture
market share as they all tend to want to
do, gain monopolies and then further
down the road charge for access to that
AGI. If on the other hand performance
can be bought through sheer scaling up
of compute then someone is going to have
to pay for that compute namely you. Yes,
we've had some quick gains going from 01
to 03 and even 04 mini but as the CEO of
anthropic said that post-training or
reasoning through reinforcement learning
is soon going to be at the cost of
billions and billions of dollars. And
nor is post-training magic. It can't
actually create reasoning paths not
found in the original base model. That's
according to a very new paper out of
Shinua University. If you're interested
in my deep dive on that paper and the
previous one you just saw, I've just put
up a 20-minute video on my Patreon.
Thank you as ever to everyone who
supports the channel via Patreon. Now,
as the former chief research officer at
OpenAI said, that doesn't mean that
there isn't lots of lowhanging fruit in
reasoning or post-training. But he
nevertheless predicts that soon
reasoning will quote catch up to
pre-training in the sense of providing
log linear returns. as in you have to
put 10 times the investment to get one
increment more of progress. Also bear in
mind that Samman recently called OpenAI
a product company as much as a model
company. It's a little bit like they're
kind of taking their eye off the AGI
ball and focusing more on dollar
returned per compute spend. These
companies only have so many GPUs and
TPUs to go around. Every time
researchers attempted toward a bigger
base model or more post-training, Samwin
has to judge that against rate limits
for new users. new feature launches and
latency. I know this research from Epoch
AI was mainly focused on scaling up
training runs or pre-training the base
models, but very broadly speaking, it
predicted by 2030 having say 100,000
times the effective compute as was used
in 2022 for the training of GPT4. But
even if hypothetically by 2030 we had
five orders of magnitude more compute
than we have say today, think of all the
competing demands on that compute OpenAI
would have if they're to achieve $174
billion of revenue. Their models by
parameter count might be a,000 times
bigger on average by then as compared to
now. Most free users until very recently
were using around an 8 billion parameter
model, GPT40 Mini. But even if free
users are now getting used to models the
size of GBC 4, GPC 4.5 is around 20
trillion parameters. Some say 12
trillion, but either way, roughly two
orders of magnitude more than GP40. Of
course, by then power users like me
won't be using GPT 4.5, but probably GPT
5 or 6, 10 or 100 times bigger. Then
there's the user base. And even though
OpenAI are serving 600 million monthly
active users, by 5 years from now, there
might be 6 billion smartphone users.
Google with Gemini recently quadrupled
its user base in just a few months up to
350 million monthly active users. But
that could easily 2x, 3x, 4x. That takes
compute and this is all before we get to
models thinking for longer. Then there's
latency. Deep research is amazing, but
it takes an average of say 5 to 10
minutes. You can imagine spending an
order of magnitude more compute to bring
that down to say 5 seconds. Also, don't
forget there's usage per user in this
2027 or 2030 scenario of AGI. Everyone
is of course going to be using these
chat bots way more than they are now.
That's another 10x and that's all before
we get to things like text to image,
text to video with Sora. All of which is
a long way of saying that I could
imagine 12 orders of magnitude of
effective compute being utilized by
companies like OpenAI. That includes
things like not just more chips, but
more efficient chips and better
algorithms. Five orders of magnitude by
2030 wouldn't be nearly enough. If you
notice, none of that actually precludes
there being a proto AGI in the coming
few years, albeit a very expensive one.
Here's what a senior staff member at
OpenAI said just a few days ago. OpenAI,
he said, has defined AGI as a highly
autonomous system that can outperform
humans at most economically valuable
work. We definitely aren't there yet.
Far from it. You might have deduced the
same with some of the benchmarks earlier
in this video. But he goes on, "The AGI
vibes are very real to me, especially
the way that 03 dynamically uses tools
as part of its chain of thought." Again,
he says that does not mean we've
achieved AGI now. In fact, it's a hill
that he would die on that we have in
fact not. He ends though, and I agree
with this, that things will go slow
until they go fast. Really fast. Things
feel fast today, but I think we're
actually still accelerating and we will
actually start to go even faster. If
you're willing to spend the money,
Francois, a famous AI researcher said,
going from cents per query up to tens of
thousands of dollars per query, you can
go from zero fluid intelligence to near
human level fluid intelligence. After
all, we're getting things like
anthropics model context protocol where
models now have a shared language to
call tools of all types. And we know
that tool calling was part of the
reinforcement learning training of 03.
So, how long is it before 03, which
arguably fails on anatomy questions like
this, can call on open- source software
like OpenSIM and run a simulation, enter
the relevant parameters and run the code
like they do with code interpreter,
watching the resultant simulation. Soon,
almost any software could be sucked into
the orbit of these models training
regimes. Now, I will grant you that
presents all sorts of security problems
that will have to be solved first. Which
is why I'm going to introduce you to the
sponsors of this video, Grace Swan. And
you may be able to see out of the corner
of your eye a $60,000 competition that's
in progress wherein you, you don't even
have to be a professional researcher,
can try to use image inputs to jailbreak
leading vision enabled AI models. I
think it's pretty insane that you can be
paid to exploit these vulnerabilities
and yet at the same time be boosting AI
safety and security. These are
incredibly legit competitions with
public leaderboards monitored by OpenAI,
Anthropic, and Google Deep Mind. So,
wouldn't it be pretty epic if the
winners of this competition turned out
to have used my unique link, which you
can find in the description? I will
completely take full credit for your win
and bask in the resultant glory. Of
course, feel free to weigh in in the
comments what you think about the news
story that's currently going viral
online. No doubt it's crazy times we
live in, but thank you guys so much for
watching to the end. I will never not be
grateful for your viewership. So have an
absolutely wonderful